und die Ausschusssitzung ist inzwischen
beendet und wir haben erste Stimmen dazu
von der Opposition von der CDU haben
sich geäußert Andreas Jung und Julia
Klöckner
wir haben lange getagt eben wir hätten
gerne öffentlich getagt denn hier geht
es um eine transparenzfrage und
normalerweise spricht nicht nur der
Minister sondern auch die Grünen davon
dass sie die transparenzpartei sind
leider wurde das heute verwehrt ich will
sehr klar sagen dass der Ausschuss nicht
als Ganzes gegen die öffentliche Tagung
sich ausgesprochen hat sondern die Ampel
Mitglieder wir haben dafür gestimmt dass
wir öffentlich tagen werden was es geben
wird ist ein Wortprotokoll das zeitnah
veröffentlicht werden soll ich will aber
für uns beide sagen da ist eine nicht
öffentliche Sitzung war dürfen wir nicht
mit Details und dürfen wir auch nicht
wortwiedergabe und Zitat Wiedergabe
nutzen und das werden wir auch eine tun
und da bitte ich auch um Ihr Verständnis
wir haben deshalb als Union das waren
wir als Opposition einen Bericht der
Bundesregierung des bmwk angefordert
über die Personal Vorgänge im bmwk uns
zu berichten und
muss er ganz offen sagen
wir haben höchste Zweifel an der Eignung
des Staatssekretärs erreichen
an der Eignung für diese Position die er
hat warum es wurde häufig auch vom
Minister davon gesprochen es wurden
Fehler gemacht es gibt einen Unterschied
zwischen menschlichem Fehler unterlaufen
uns allen aber so lapidar die Vorgänger
als Fehler abzutun halten wir für falsch
wenn das die Überzeugung ist dann wird
es im übrigen auch keine Änderungen in
Zukunft bei ähnlichen Vorgängen geben
denn hier haben wir einen ganz klaren
Verstoß gegen auch den Kodex ein
Verhaltenskodex den auch Mitglieder der
Bundesregierung ausgehändigt bekommen
und an denen sie sich halten müssen und
deshalb ist unsere Forderung auch dass
überprüft wird das auch ein
Disziplinarverfahren aufgrund eines
Verstoßes auch in Angriff genommen wird
ein weiterer Punkt den ich ja der mich
wirklich hier umtreibt sind ja nicht
einzelne Fragestellungen wer mit wem
verwandt ist wenngleich das ja auch doch
recht evident ist aber der Punkt ist
dass trotz besseren Wissens ist
personalverflechtungen gibt in
rund um das bmwk und im bmwk im
Wirtschaftsministerium und das ein
Staatssekretär so lange nichts gesagt
hat über die Beziehung zu seinem
Trauzeugen so lange nicht bis wir als
Opposition im Übrigen in einer
Plenardebatte einen Hinweis gegeben
hatten und deshalb sagen wir auch sehr
klar hier wurde dann auch wenn das
stimmt was wir gehört haben der Minister
getäuscht von seinem Staatssekretär und
deshalb müsste das unserer Meinung nach
auch Konsequenzen haben grundsätzlich
ist es wenn man etwas etwas höher
aufhängt auch eine Frage von Demokratie
Verständnis wenn wir ein ganz enges
Geflecht vorfinden von Familien Freundes
und auch von der Energie sogenannten
Energie Community die miteinander
verflochten ist die sich gegenseitig
auch das bestätigt mit Gutachten was
wiederum vom Ministerium als Ziel in der
sogenannten Klimawende
heizungsumbauzwang vorgelegt wird und
das Problem ist wenn Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und wenn Experten wenn
Wissenschaftler Zweifel an Berechnungen
auch auf den Tisch legen dass man da
kaum
durchdringt das ist so wenn man auch
ideologisch an was rangeht dann bekommt
man ein schlechtes Gewissen wenn Fakten
was anderes sagen und deshalb geht es
uns schon um die Frage wird durch ein
solches Geflecht eben auch dass man ohne
Hemmungen ohne dass man es sagt mit
einer Vielzahl von Bewerbern just den
eigenen Trauzeugen dann auch noch
vorschlägt und sie werden es im
Protokoll sehen wie dieser trauzeug auch
angesprochen worden ist wie Herr
Graichen sich eingesetzt hat oder nicht
wie gesagt davon dürfen wir jetzt nicht
berichten sie werden es lesen in
Protokoll das veröffentlicht wird all
dieses zeigt nicht nur eine gewisse
Hemmungslosigkeit sondern auch ein
Verständnis was als lapidaren Fehler
abgetan wird aber was wirklich
dienstrechtlich enorme Auswirkungen hat
und deshalb sagen wir sehr klar das
Vertrauen in Entscheidungen die für das
Wohl des Landes getroffen werden sollen
auch im Sinne des Klimaschutzes werden
natürlich im Zweifel gezogen wenn diese
Vorbereitung dieser Entscheidung
wirklich in einer sehr sehr engen Gruppe
die sich seit Jahren sehr sehr gut kennt
vorab gesprochen wird und das nur als
leichten Fehler abgetan wird und dann
Herr Habeck auch an diesem
Staatssekretär festhält wir werden heute
eine Aktuelle Stunde dazu noch haben es
gibt viele offene Fragen und an diesen
Fragen werden wir auch weiter dran
bleiben
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
auch von meiner Seite auch von meiner
Seite einen guten Tag die ampelfraktion
haben heute eine große Chance vertan für
Aufklärung und Transparenz zu sorgen
Robert Habeck hat hier erkennen lassen
er wäre für eine öffentliche Sitzung
bereitgestanden die Grünen aber mit den
anderen Ampel Fraktionen heute dreimal
dagegen gestimmt einmal im
energieausschuss einmal im
Wirtschaftsausschuss und dann auch noch
mal hier in der gemeinsamen Sitzung das
kann man kaum glauben man fragt sich
reden die eigentlich überhaupt
miteinander wenn Robert habe ich hier
gerne öffentlich Stellung genommen und
doch davor SPD und FDP umfassende
Transparenz gefördert haben liegt es
dann an den Grünen man kann sich nur
schwer ein Bild machen wieder die
Abläufe sind aber fest steht damit das
mit dem heutigen Tage die Sache nicht
erledigt ist die Aufklärung muss
weitergehen wir werden als Union den
Antrag stellen dass wir eine
weitere Ausschusssitzung machen und dann
öffentlich tagen es sind ja die Dinge
öffentlich geworden die werden
öffentlich diskutiert es gibt ein
öffentliches Interesse und deshalb
brauchen wir selbstverständlich auch
eine öffentliche Sitzung und klar ist
auch die Dinge müssen weiter
aufgearbeitet werden es steht zwar fest
dass ein Fehler begangen wurde weil
staatssekretärchen trotzdem engen
Freundschaft zu einem Bewerber sich
nicht aus diesem Verfahren zurückgezogen
hat aber es stellt sich die Frage welche
Rolle er denn in diesem Verfahren
gestellt hat ob er lediglich sich nicht
rausgenommen hat oder aber eine aktive
Rolle für ein am engen Freund
eingenommen hat um hier eine
entsprechende Besetzung zu unterstützen
fest steht jedenfalls dass die
Findungskommission nur einen Bewerber
dem Aufsichtsrat vorgeschlagen hat
versteht dass dieser
Server die Stelle jetzt nicht antreten
wird aber offen völlig offen ist aus
unserer Sicht was ist nun für Folgen hat
für den Vertrag von Michael Schäfer
offen ist aus unserer Sicht wie das
compliance-verfahren weitergeht ist der
Minister angestrengt hat nachdem Patrick
reichen ihm sehr spät
berichtet hat dass es diese persönliche
Verbindung gibt insofern muss die
Aufarbeitung weitergehen muss die
Transparenz hergestellt werden und
werden wir eine öffentliche Sitzung
beantragen wo zu all dem hier
tatsächlich dann so Stellung genommen
werden kann dass es öffentliche
Interesse zu diesen Fragen beantwortet
werden können genau es wird ja zumindest
heute auf jeden Fall auch noch eine
Aktuelle Stunde zu diesem Thema geben
auch mit dem Minister im Bundestag
ungefähr 15 20 sehen Sie dann hier live
bei Phoenix aber jetzt wollen wir
erstmal sprechen mit Professor Volker
Kronenberg Politik Wissenschaftler von
der Uni Bonn herzlich willkommen bei uns
im Studio in Bonn ja vielen Dank
verlegen also wir haben natürlich die
Kritik der
Opposition gehört auch in den
vergangenen Tagen die
Rücktrittsforderungen in Richtung
Patrick reichen aus ihrer Sicht
berechtigt
wir kennen glaube ich alle nicht die
politischen Akteure in Berlin aber die
Öffentlichkeit auch nicht die das
wirkliche Ausmaß dessen was sich da
ereignet hat wer hat wann was gewusst
und sich warum wie verhalten und wie ist
das zu bewerten
und das wird ja immer wieder auch
angedeutet das wird ja auch aus den
Reihen der
Koalitionspartner angedeutet dass man
Aufklärung haben will das macht einen ja
schon stutzig sozusagen
Unterstützung klingt anders insofern ist
das eine Steilvorlage für die Opposition
die Union und die anderen
Oppositionsparteien hier reinzugehen
aber egal von Davis ob das nun am Ende
Compliance rechtlich das oder jenes wie
das dann am Ende zu bewerten ist es ist
ja eine politische Frage eben auch und
sie sagen zu Recht die Rücktritts
Aufforderungen inzwischen nach einigen
Tagen muss man ja fast schon fragen an
wen denn adressiert immer noch an den
Staatssekretär oder womöglich schon auf
an den Minister und damit möchte ich
darauf hinaus dass er diese Affäre
dieses Politikum droht sozusagen ein
Ausmaß anzunehmen das womöglich eben
auch den Minister selbst seine
handlungsfäh Möglichkeit und seine
Durchsetzungsfähigkeit droht zu
beschädigen und spätestens da ist ja
dann noch einmal jenseits der der
justiziabilität auch von Vorwürfen da
natürlich eine rote Linie ich gehe davon
aus stand heute in der Einschätzung
dessen was wir seit Tagen erlebt haben
und was noch kommt dass der
Staatssekretär sich nicht wird halten
können okay
die andere Personalie die Sie
angesprochen haben das ist etwas was
Friedrich Merz gestern auch ins Spiel
gebracht hat nicht direkt aber indirekt
indem er diesen Vorfall im Prinzip
verglichen hat mit dem Fall Möllemann
Wirtschaftsminister der zurückgetreten
ist wegen eines Flyers so hat Friedrich
Merz ist dann genannt kann man das
Vergleichen aus ihrer Sicht
bei Vergleichen gibt es immer
Gemeinsamkeiten und Unterschiede und
hier würden mir erstmal die Unterschiede
es waren ganz anderer zeitlicher Kontext
ein ganz andere Personen ganz anderer
Vorgang
Gemeinsamkeiten Unterschiede aber wie
Ihr sehen ja das im politischen ist
nicht nur darum geht was ist rechtlich
zulässig gewesen und so weiter und so
fort sondern es geht ja um mehr das
Stichwort wir haben es gerade bei Frau
Klöckner gehört aber das ist jetzt nicht
nur ein oppositionsbegriff sondern es
ist ein Schlüsselbegriff der Politik
auch für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Vertrauen und Vertrauen eben dann hier
in einen Akteur den Minister nicht den
den Staatssekretär den die
Öffentlichkeit nicht wirklich kennt
sondern der Staatssekretär steht
letztendlich auch für den der an der
Spitze steht das ist der Minister und
das ist nicht irgendwer sondern das ist
natürlich eben auch das sind die Grünen
das sind die Grünen auch mit ihrem
Anspruch an Politik und an Transparenz
und das was man moralisch tun kann und
was man nicht tun sollte selbst wenn es
rechtlich zulässig ist also sagen will
ist da sehr viele im Raum Stichwort
Vertrauen und ich glaube unsere nehme
ich Herrn Harbeck auch war dass sie kann
natürlich immer weiter auch durch die
Frage wird tatsächlich sein kann man das
ernsthaft durchstehen auch durchstehen
wollen
schauen wir gleich noch mal ein bisschen
auf das große Ganze wir haben auch
Landtagswahlen vor der Brust in Bremen
da würde ich gerne mit Ihnen noch mal
auf die Grünen schauen einmal aber noch
tatsächlich bei Harbeck und Herrn
reichen bleiben Robert habert Habeck hat
ja seinem Staatssekretär den Rücken
gestärkt und seine Verdienste
hervorgehoben und gesagt wenn wir ihn
nicht hätten wir hätten eine große
Energiekrise aber ist das so kann man
das eine gegen das andere aufwiegen oder
das Gegeneinander Stellen eigentlich
denn ich glaube das war am Wochenende
eine klare Entscheidung des Ministers
und der Person Robert Habeck sich so zu
positionieren erstmal zu sagen ich stehe
ich stehe zu einem engen Weggefährten zu
einem Ganzen wichtigen Mitarbeiter
niemand ist unersetzlich auch Patrick
reichen wäre natürlich in dieser
Funktion als Architekt der Energiewende
natürlich ersetzbar weil da gibt es
schon auch noch andere Experten aber er
hat sich ja politisch auch habe ich
bewusster zu entschieden zu sagen diesen
Gegenwind dem äh halte ich jetzt erstmal
etwas entgegen ich stehe zu meinem äh
Staatssekretär wohl wissend dass ich
natürlich die Konstellation auch ändern
kann das können neue Erkenntnisse sein
das können andere Faktoren sein denn
Stichwort Architekt der Energiewende es
geht ja hier auch in der Sache in diesem
Wochen und Monaten um sehr sehr viel und
wenn das eine sozusagen droht das andere
in Mitleidenschaft zu ziehen dann wird
der Minister eine politische
Gesamtabwägung treffen aber er hat
zunächst dazu entschlossen ganz bewusst
politisch zu sagen dem halte ich stand
okay es geht um eine große Sache aus
Seiten des Ministers da geht es im
Moment um das Gebäude Energiegesetz was
ansteht sehr unbeliebt auch bei den
Koalitionspartnern oder ein
Koalitionspartner aber natürlich auch
bei der Opposition und auch dort klang
es jetzt so an dass man sagt man sieht
dieses ganze Gesetz aufgrund dieser
Vorfälle in Zweifel wie würden Sie das
sehen also wo sind wir da an der Stelle
sind wir da bei immer noch bei
berechtigter Kritik oder geht das dann
auch schon so ein bisschen in Richtung
Kampagne
würde sagen dass das ist das Verknüpfen
von unterschiedlichen Zusammenhängen
aber das ist ja nichts Neues so
funktionieren natürlich Politik dass man
dann eben hier über einen
personalvorgang das ganze auf die Sache
auch ausweitet und dann nimmt man auch
den Minister und dann nimmt man das
große Ganze und die Energiewende und wie
man es macht und diese Aspekt und die
Heizung und das dieser Gesetzentwurf
dann nimmt man das alles zusammen das
ist der Punkt auf den ich hier heute
hinweisen würde das ist hoch gefährlich
das weiß Robert Habeck das wissen die
Grünen das wissen die Grünen auch wenige
Tage vor der Bremen weil das kann man
sagen Bremen die hilft größte Stadt naja
aber die die politische psychologische
Wirkung ist natürlich wichtig vielleicht
noch wichtiger als aktuelle Umfragen die
nimmt man aber zur Kenntnis dass die
grüne natürlich runter gehen dass die
AFD sehr zulegt Frustration und
Zufriedenheit
Unwillen sozusagen mit dem wie man das
managed und überhaupt das große Ganze
was die Ampel da abliefert das lässt
natürlich bei den Grünen und bei Robert
Habeck natürlich die Alarmglocken
schrillen man wird das Ganze nicht mehr
über Tage und Wochen ziehen kann ist
viel zu viel Aufmerksamkeit auf eine
Personalie die man lenken muss auf
Sachen Inhalte und sagten uns gerade
noch mal weitere Stimmen hören ich höre
wir haben vorliegen eine Stimme nach dem
Wirtschaftsausschuss jetzt auch ähm von
der FDP es beginnt Olaf in der Bibel
ja schönen guten Tag Olaf in der Beeck
mein Name Obmann der Freien Demokraten
im Ausschuss für Klima und Energie und
Reinhard Hoven wirtschaftsprüher
Sprecher und Obmann der Freien
Demokraten im Ausschuss für Wirtschaft
eine kurze Einschätzung von unserer
Seite wir sind erstmal sehr dankbar dass
der Minister und drei Staatssekretäre zu
der Sondersitzung ins Parlament gekommen
sind dass wir Ihnen Fragen stellen
konnten wir finden auch dass sich alle
wirklich große Mühe gegeben haben diese
Fragen auch wirklich zu beantworten und
denken auch dass das gut ist dass wir
genau da mit der Transparenz starten
wovon wir beide auch in der letzten
Sitzungswoche im Parlament gesprochen
haben nämlich das mehr Transparenz her
muss
also es war schon zu spüren dass
Minister habe ich emotional angefasst
war in dieser Sitzung das kann man
glaube ich schon berichten und die
Vorgänge um die neue Besetzung der
Dehner
wird weitere Fragen aufwerfen es ist
angesprochen worden dass geprüft wird ob
ein Disziplinarverfahren
eingeleitet wird gegen Herrn reichen
darüber hinaus gibt es unter Umständen
finanzielle Rechte von Herrn Schäfer aus
den Verhandlungen mit der Dehner
darüber hinaus ist ja die Frage gestellt
worden wie das Verfahren war was die
Öffentlichkeit angeht dann brauche ich
vielleicht eine Frage nicht sozusagen
herausfordern es ist so dass das
Verfahren zwei gemeinsame Sitzungen zu
machen nicht öffentlich abgestimmt war
in der Ampelkoalition das war auch bis
heute morgen um 8:15 Uhr so und dann
sind die Grünen auf SPD und FDP
zugekommen und wollten das Verfahren
ändern und dann haben wir unseren
Koalitionspartnern gesagt nein packt da
sonst der Wanda wir ziehen das jetzt in
der Form durch wie die ganze Zeit
besprochen
gibt es Fragen
na ja ich glaube wir müssen jetzt
feststellen dass erstmal die Überprüfung
eines Disziplinarverfahrens eingeleitet
worden ist und das ist ja Beamtenrecht
ich bin jetzt kein Beamten Jurist oder
kein Jurist der sich damit gut auskennt
ich kann nur sagen es ist auf dem Weg
und es wird immer prüft ob er dort
disziplinarische Fehler gemacht hat und
daraus sind werden für einen Beamten für
einen Beamten sicherlich Konsequenzen
erfolgen oder nicht die Personalhoheit
und Entscheidung liegt bei Minister
jeden Fall kann eben Staatssekretär
festhalten egal
nein das hat der Minister nicht
festgelegt weil der Minister sehr
deutlich darauf hingewiesen hat dass
eine Überprüfung eines
Disziplinarverfahrens läuft
wissen sie im Politik Management muss
man sich darauf verlassen können dass
Absprachen funktionieren und
außerdem haben wir in den Vorgesprächen
festgelegt dass wir nicht öffentlich
tagen wollen damit eben auch mehr
Informationen an die Abgeordneten kommen
denn bei dem Interesse was sie hier so
sehe könnte ich mir vorstellen dass eine
öffentliche Sitzung überhaupt gar keine
besonderen Informationen zu uns
Abgeordneten gebracht hätte und deswegen
sind Sozialdemokraten und FDP dabei
geblieben eben nicht öffentlich zu tagen